Transcriber: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
(Alkış)
Merhabalar.
1997 yılının Mart ayında,
İstanbul Teknik Üniversitesinde,
bir popüler bilim konferansı yapmıştık.
Orada ben de yapay zeka
hakkında konuşmuştum.
Konuşmamda, kısa süre sonra insanların,
Dünya İnsan Satranç şampiyonunun,
bir bilgisayar tarafından yenileceğini
iddia etmiştim.
Bunun üzerine,
oradaki izleyicilerden biriyle
hararetli bir tartışmaya girmiştik.
Bunun asla mümkün olmadığını,
insanların satranç oynarken
bilgisayarların asla sahip olamayacağı
bir şey kullandığını iddia eden
bir izleyici ile.
Keşke bahse girseymişim, çünkü bu olayın
üstünden iki ay falan geçtikten sonra,
Dünya İnsan Satranç Şampiyonu
Garri Kasparov,
New York'taki bir maçta,
IBM şirketinin Deep Blue adlı
bilgisayarına feci şekilde yenildi.
Ben de, bir uzman olarak, haklı çıkmanın
gururunu yaşadım.
Ama aynı gururu, bu senenin
başlarında, yaşayamadım.
Çünkü, 2015 yılında ben dahil
herhangi bir yapay zeka hocasına,
ünlü Uzak Doğu oyunu Go'nun
ne zaman bilgisayarlar tarafından
ele geçirileceğini, ne zaman Go
şampiyonunun bilgisayarlar tarafından
yenileceğini sorsanız,
ohoo o işe en az on yıl var derdik.
Ama, şu olay 2016'nın
mart ayında gerçekleşti.
Dünyanın en iyi oyuncularından
Güney Koreli Lee Sedol,
Google Deep Mind şirketinin
bizden gizli geliştirmiş olduğu
Alfa Go adlı bir bilgisayar
programına yenildi.
Yapay zeka da, bir girdap gibi
yavaş başlayıp giderek hızlanan
ve bizi etkisi altına alan,
kendine uzman diyenleri bile şaşırtan
bir hızla ilerliyor.
Olayı biraz baştan alalım.
Hikâyemiz 1769 yılında,
şu beyefendi tarafından başlatıldı:
Gottfried Wilhelm Leibniz.
Çok büyük bir adam, ama bizim
konumuzla ilgili olan kısmı,
inşa etmiş olduğu bu makine.
Bu makine tarihte dört aritmetik işlemi,
toplama, çıkarma, çarpma, bölme,
hepsini birden gerçekleştirebilen
ilk mekanik cihaz.
Ve Leibniz bu kadarla kalmamış,
insan zihni gerektiren bu ulvi işi
yapabilen bir makine yapabildiğimize göre,
insan zihninin geri kalan
faaliyetlerini de, düşünmeyi de,
muhakeme etmeyi de makineye
yaptırabiliriz, diye düşünmüş.
Ama bunun için, aritmetik sembollerini
yazıp gösterebildiğimiz
bir dilimizin olduğu gibi,
düşünce işlemlerini de, formel olarak
matematik gibi gösterebilen bir dile
ihtiyaç var, demiş.
Bunu demesinden 175 yıl sonra,
şu beyefendi, George Boole,
İngiliz matematikçi, esasen
bu dili ortaya çıkarmış.
Artık George Boole sayesinde,
doğru ve yanlış gibi kavramları
bir ve sıfır gibi rakamlarla ifade edip
ve veya ise gibi cümleler arası
ilişki kuran işleçleri,
tıpkı bir matematik
dilinde gösterebiliyoruz,
her şeyi Boole başlatmış.
Boole'un attığı bu temel üzerine, 1910'da
Bertrand Russell adlı çok ünlü İngiliz,
matematik ile mantık madem evlendi,
işe öbür yönden bakalım;
matematikle hiçbir şeyin,
hiçbir yanlışın kanıtlanamayacağını,
matematiğin bu anlamda sağlam olduğunu
gösterelim, diye bir altyapı kurmuş.
Bu altyapıyı kullanan Kurt Gödel
adlı dahi matematikçi, 1931 yılında,
matematik dünyasına bir bomba atmış,
çünkü matematikte bir tür
delik olduğunu keşfetmiş,
bazı gerçeklerin, asla matematik
sistemi ile kanıtlanamayacağını,
bunun matematikçilerin
beceriksizliğinden değil,
matematiğin doğasının, kendi
eksikliğinden olduğunu ortaya koymuş.
Bunun konumuzla ne ilgisi var?
Şu ilgisi var.
Gödel'in bu çalışmasından etkilenen,
benim en sevdiğim bilim adamı Alan Turing,
1936 yılında, bazı soruların asla hiçbir
bilgisayar ya da hiçbir fizik kurallarına
göre çalışan mekanizma tarafından
yanıtlanamayacağının mükemmel bir
ispatını ortaya koymuş ve bu ispatı
ortaya koyduğu makalede de,
bir tür yan ürün olarak,
şimdi artık Turing makinesi dediğimiz,
bir tür makine tarif etmiş.
Bu makine harika bir makine,
çünkü başka her tür sistemi
taklit edebilen bir makine.
Turing bunu kağıt üzerinde bırakmamış,
1. Dünya Savaşında değil,
2. Dünya Savaşındaki birtakım
kahramanlıklarından sonra,
1946'da, böyle makineleri
nasıl gerçek dünyada
inşa edebileceğimizin de örneğini vermiş.
İngiltere'de inşa edilen ilk elektronik
bilgisayarı yapan insanlar arasında
Turing de varmış, o kadarla da kalmamış,
bu makinelerin potansiyelini anlamış
ve 1950'de, bu makineler gerçekten
bütün bilişsel faaliyet gösteren
varlıkları taklit edebildiklerine göre,
2000 yılına doğru,
bunlara resmen zeki diyebileceğiz,
bütün zeka gerektiren işleri de
yapabilecekler ve onlara zeki denildiğinde
insanlar bunu yadırgamayacak,
diye bir öngörüde bulunmuş.
1956'da, Amerika'da Dartmouth
konferansı diye önemli bir
bilimsel toplantı yapıldı.
Şimdi 2016 yılındayız.
Dartmouth konferansı,
yapay zekanın başlangıcı sayılır.
Demek ki yapay zeka
çalışmalarının 50. yılındayız.
Bu süre boyunca, işler yavaş başlayıp
giderek hızlanarak bizi bugüne getirdi.
Yapay zeka tekniklerini
ben üçe ayırarak anlatıyorum.
Başlangıçta bilgisayarlara zekice işleri
yapmalarının nasıl bir yöntemi olduğunu,
''anlatarak öğretme'' dediğim
bir yöntemle öğretiyorduk.
Yani mesela satranç buna güzel bir örnek.
Satranç oynayan bilgisayarları
programlayan programcılar,
önce satrancın nasıl oynandığını
kendileri gayet iyi anlıyordu,
nasıl kazanılabileceğine dair, çok detaylı
aptala anlatır gibi, adım adım bir
talimatnameyi hazırlayıp bilgisayara
yüklüyorlardı, onu programlıyorlardı yani.
Ve bilgisayar da, herhangi bir insandan
bunu çok daha hızlı icra edebileceği için
herhangi bir insandan,
söz gelimi dünya şampiyonundan,
daha iyi satranç oynar hale geliyordu.
Bu anlatarak öğretmenin özelliği,
sizin o bilişsel faaliyeti çok iyi anlamış
anlatabilir hale gelmiş olmanız
gerekiyor programlayabilmek için.
Ama bazı faaliyetler için,
bu sistemi kullanamadık.
Mesela, bir resmin içinde bir
arkadaşımızın görüntüsünü tanımak gibi.
Çünkü biz insanlar bunu
çok rahat yapabiliyoruz ama,
bunu nasıl yaptığımızı bilmiyoruz.
Ama Allah'tan bunu da bilgisayarlara
yaptırmanın bir yolunu bulduk,
benim göstererek öğretme dediğim yöntemde.
Bir resmin içinde amcamın yüzünün
var olduğunu tanıma yeteneğini
bilgisayara göstermek istersem,
o resmi oluşturan binlerce renk
noktasından oluşan diziyi
bilgisayara veriyorum ve içinde
amcamın olduğu resimlerde evet,
amcamın olmadığı resimlerde hayır diyerek
binlerce, binlerce olumlu ve olumsuz
örnek gösteriyorum bilgisayarıma.
Bilgisayarım da, kendi insan beynine
benzetilerek hazırlanmış milyonlarca
parametreden oluşan gösteriminde,
her seferinde küçük değişiklikler yaparak,
bu tanıma işinde yaptığı
hatayı giderek azaltıyor,
birsüre sonra benim amcamı
gerçekten daha önce örnekler sırasında
hiç göstermediğim yeni resimlerde bile,
var yok diye tanıyabilen
bir programımız oluyor.
Artık bu iş, bilgisayarlar tarafından
yapılabilir hale geldi.
Ama beni en heyecanlandıran,
benim ''kendi kendine öğrenme''
dediğim teknik,
orada bilgisayarlarımız artık,
mesela bu Go şampiyonunu yenen
Alfa Go'nun yaptığı gibi,
göstererek öğretmenin ötesine
geçen bir teknikle öğreniyorlar.
Alfa Go'ya hiçkimse Go şampiyonu
nasıl yenilir, diye anlatarak
ya da göstererek öğretmedi,
çünkü hiçkimse Go şampiyonunu
nasıl yeneceğini bilmiyordu.
Alfa Go,
yüz elli bin kadar insan Go oyununu görüp
insanlar nasıl yapıyor bu işi
şeklinde öğrendikten sonra,
kendi kendine binlerce,
on binlerce defa maçlar oynayıp
kendi kopyalarından hangisi
bir maç sırasında galip geldiyse,
parametrelerini ona
benzetecek şekilde ayarlayıp
kendi tecrübesini yaratarak,
insanüstü seviyeye geldi.
Yapay zeka, aldı başını gidiyor.
Ve gerçekten de
yapay zeka bizi de mutlu ediyor.
Bugün yapay zeka kullanan, yani
cep telefonu kullanan demek istiyorum,
insanlar, bu özelliğe sahip olmayan
insanlardan on kat daha iyi yaşıyorlar.
Trafikte daha kolay yoldan,
daha kısa zamanda gidiyorlar.
Hatta yavaş yavaş bazı ülkelerde,
trafik derdinde kendileri
araba sürmek zorunda da kalmıyor.
Başka, dilini bilmedikleri
insanlarla anlaşabiliyorlar.
Yepyeni bir arkadaş edinme şekilleri var
ve kendilerine ilgi alanı
açısından uygun insanlarla,
dünyanın öbür ucunda olsa bile
bilgisayar tarafından tanıştırılıp
güzel arkadaşlıklar kurabiliyorlar ve
tabii ki burada bütün örnekleri veremem,
çünkü gerçekten bir TED konuşmasına
sığmayacak kadar çok güzel şeyler
kazandırıyor yapay zeka bize.
Ama bir de işin bazı insanları
korkutan bir yönü var,
karanlık mı desem bilmiyorum.
Güney Kore'de bir şirket,
tamamen kendi kendine çalışan,
yani insanların hiç işe karışmadığı
uzaktan bir insan geldiğinde
ona nişan alıp ateş eden bir
akıllı otomatik silah geliştirmiş durumda.
Amerika'da, savaş uçağı pilotlarının
bu işi öğrenirken geçmek zorunda olduğu
simülasyon programlarından birinde,
bütün insanlardan, uzman insanlar dahil,
bütün insanlardan daha yüksek not alan
bir savaş uçağı uçurma programı var.
Acaba ipin ucunu kaçırıyor muyuz?
Şu örnek, ki bu da
2016'nın Mart ayında yaşandı,
belki bize bir fikir verebilir.
Microsoft şirketi,
Tay adında bir
Twitter karakteri icat etti,
bu ergen bir kızı simüle etmek
fikri üzerine kurulmuştu.
Tay'in özelliği, o tweet'ler atacak,
insanlar da ona cevap verecek
ve öğrenme özelliğine sahip,
bu şekilde insanların dil
özelliklerini daha iyi öğrenecek.
Bu haberde görebileceğimiz gibi, işte
böylelikle daha doğal konuşacak diyordu,
öğrenme özelliği sayesinde.
Bu haberden, yani Tay'in
açılmasından tam 24 saat sonra,
şu haber çıktı.
Tay biraz fazla öğrenmişti,
birtakım kötü niyetli insanlar
onunla öyle abuk subuk konuşmuşlardı ki,
24 saat içinde Tay; Hitler hayranı,
soykırım çok iyi bir şeydir diyen,
abuk subuk seksle ilgili şeyler söyleyen,
nefret edilecek bir karaktere dönüşmüştü.
Ve Microsoft hemen
o saatte hesabı kapattı.
Yani biz bilgisayarlara
kötülüğü de öğretebiliyoruz.
Maalesef.
Bilgisayarlarımız giderek zeki oluyor,
demin anlatmaya çalıştığım,
bu iyi bir şey.
Çünkü bu bize, birkaç yıl öncesine
kadar aklımıza bile gelmeyen,
ama bizim çocuklarımızın,
vazgeçmeyi bile düşünemeyecekleri kadar
yaşamsal yararlar sağlıyor.
Ama öte yandan, fazla akıllanırlarsa,
kontrolü fazla ele geçirirlerse,
acaba bize bir kötülük yaparlar mı,
kötü insanların elinde nasıl bir hal
alırlar diye korkanlar da var.
Bazı kişiler bunun, bu ihtimalle
mücadele için diyorlar ki,
bazı bilişsel faaliyetlerin bilgisayarlar
tarafından yapılmasını yasaklayalım.
Yani bu tip yeteneklere sahip
bilgisayarların, programların
üretilmesini yasaklayalım.
Benim gördüğüm kadarıyla,
tarihte bariz nedenlerden ötürü,
eğer bir özellik, bir alet sahip olan
kişilere bir rekabet avantajı veriyorsa,
böyle yasaklar hiç işlemiyor.
Siz yasağa uyan insanlar olarak, yasağa
uymayanların gerisinde kalıyorsunuz.
O yüzden ben bunun
çalışacağına pek inanmıyorum.
Başka bir fikir de,
bildiğiniz gibi,
o zaman bilgisayarlarımıza
bir tür ahlak kazandıralım.
Isaac Asimov'un, Amerikan
bilim kurgu yazarı Isaac Asimov'un,
Robotik Yasaları diye
ünlü bir buluşu vardır.
Okumuşsanız bilirsiniz,
Asimov'un romanlarındaki robotlar
daha fabrikada birtakım
ahlak yasalarıyla donatılırlar;
yani insanlara asla zarar vermeyeceksin,
kendini koruyacaksın,
ama eğer bir insana
zarar vermek söz konusuysa,
kendini korumayacaksın filan gibi.
Bu temeller, o kadar onların beynine
gömülüdür ki, asla bundan çıkamazlar.
Ve Asimov'un romanları,
böyle bir ahlak sistemine sahip robotların
başına gelen ilginç olaylarla doludur.
Bence buna benzer bir şey,
yani ya bizim kodlamamız buradaki gibi,
ya da demin bahsettiğim
öğrenme sistemlerini kullanarak
iyi ahlaklı davranışlarımızı gösterek
bilgisayarlarımıza öğretmemiz
iyi bir çözüm olur gibi geliyor.
Yine bu senenin başlarında,
hatta başlarında da değil
sanırım iki ay falan önce,
şu örneğin olduğu bir makale yayınladım,
birkaç konuşmamda da bahsettim.
Bu, Google'ın ünlü çeviri sisteminin
Türkçe-İngilizce arasındaki
çevirileri ile ilgileniyorum.
Ve Türkçe'den İngilizce'ye
''Ben bir politikacıyım,'' diye
çevrilmesi gereken bir cümleyi,
''Ben politikacı değilim,''
diye çeviriyor yıllardan beri.
Bunun teknik nedenlerini
falan da anlatabilirim isterseniz.
Ama şu daha komikti.
İngilizce'den Türkçe'ye, ''Davutoğlu iklim
değişikliğine önem veriyor,'' cümlesini,
ısrarlı şekilde
''Obama iklim değişikliğine
önem veriyor,'' diye çeviriyordu,
buna çok gülmüştük.
Ama şimdi telefonunuzu açıp bakarsanız,
böyle yapmadığını göreceksiniz.
Çünkü bir ay önce Google,
bir Sinirsel Makine Çevirisi Sistemi
diye bir yeni sisteme geçti
ve bu gibi örnekler artık çok
mükemmel şekilde çevrilebiliyor.
Hatta, Türkçe eğitim veren
üniversitelerdeki hocaların başına
yeni bir sorun açılmak üzere,
çünkü teknik çeviriyi çok iyi yapıyor
ve artık öğrencinizin yazdığı bir
makaleyi ya da bir tezi, hop diye
İngilizce bir yerden bulup çevirip
size vermediğinden emin olamayacaksınız.
Aynı şekilde otomatik olarak
insanlara şu kandırma e-postalarını
gönderen yabancılar da artık Türkçe'yi,
eskisine oranla
çok daha iyi kullanabilecek.
Biz bilgisayarlarımızı
çocuklarımız gibi görmeliyiz.
Onlardan vazgeçemeyiz.
Onlara doğru yolu göstermek de
bizim sorumluluğumuz.
Böylece, kötü insanlar
ve kötü bilgisayarlara karşı
ancak böylece biz birlikte
mücadele edebiliriz.
Teşekkürler.
(Alkış)